Amy McGuiness flies people to the North Pole, tourists who pay thousands of dollars for the privilege. It's a six-hour flight in a prop jet. And for most of that time, if you look out the window, all you see is ice. When you get to the Pole, it looks exactly like all the other ice you've been staring at for hours.
艾米·麦吉尼斯（Amy McGuiness）带着游客飞往北极，这些游客为此支付了数千美元。这是一段时长六小时的螺旋桨飞机航程。在这段时间里，如果你望向窗外，看到的只有冰。当你到达北极点时，它看起来和你盯着看了好几个小时的其他冰层没什么两样。
So the tourists climb out of the plane. They're only given half an hour at the Pole. And what do most of them do with the time? Take pictures. And most of them have brought these little global positioning devices, GPSs. And they spend their time looking at the devices which tell them that yes, this is, in fact, the North Pole. Here's Amy McGuiness.
于是游客们爬下飞机。他们在北极点只有半小时的时间。大多数人会用这段时间做什么？拍照。他们大多带了这种小型全球定位设备，即GPS。他们花时间看着这些设备，它们会告诉他们：没错，这就是北极点。下面是艾米·麦吉尼斯。
Getting out of the plane and looking around, there'd be nothing to tell you that you're at the North Pole. They can usually verify it by just powering up the GPS.
走出飞机四下张望，你会发现没有任何东西能证明你身处北极点。他们通常只需要启动GPS就能核实这一点。
I realize, actually, as we talk, I have no picture in my head of what would be at the North Pole except what you would see in a kid's cartoon, which is a barber pole sticking out of the ground. But there's no such a thing, right?
我意识到，当我们交谈时，除了儿童动画片里那种从地里冒出来的红白相间的柱子，我的脑海中对于北极点到底是什么样子的完全没有概念。但根本没有那种东西，对吧？
No, and it seems ridiculous, and I laugh, but I've had passengers ask, "Where's the barber pole?"
没有，这听起来很可笑，我虽然觉得好笑，但确实有乘客问过：“那个条纹柱子在哪里？”
Oh really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah. But we usually, with the groups, we take up some kind of a fake barber pole and stick it in the ice somewhere, just for pictures' sake.
是的。但我们通常会带一些伪造的柱子，随便插在某个冰面上，专门为了拍照用。
Oh my.
天哪。
Yeah.
没错。
There are the people who always want to know where they are in the world. They move through the world checking their position. And there's a kind of travel that we all do sometimes that's all about that moment of "You are here." You check where you are. You check your position on the map. You take a snapshot. You move on.
总有一些人想知道自己身处世界的何处。他们穿行于世界，不断确认自己的位置。我们有时都会进行一种旅行，完全专注于“你在这里”的那一刻。你核实所在位置，在地图上确认坐标，拍一张快照，然后继续前行。
The North Pole is just an extreme example. Because, of course, there's nothing there, no one to meet, you're only there for half an hour. It costs $30,000 per person. And, until recently, a regular civilian would have no way to confirm that they were at the North Pole since normal compasses, like the one on the airplane that Amy McGuiness flies--
北极点只是一个极端的例子。因为当然，那里什么都没有，没有要见的人，你只在那里待半小时。每人花费3万美元。而且，直到最近，普通平民根本无法确认自己是否真的到了北极点，因为普通的指南针，比如艾米·麦吉尼斯驾驶的那架飞机上的——
Because we're so close to the magnetic North Pole that it basically tips in the jar it's sitting in and is unreliable. It'll be 60 degrees off the proper heading.
因为我们离磁北极太近了，指南针基本上会在外壳里倾斜，变得不可靠。它会偏离正确航向60度。
It tips as if to say, "Oh, forget it."
它倾斜的样子仿佛在说：“哦，算了吧。”
Yeah, exactly.
是的，正是如此。
And then there's this sort of person who kind of enjoys the moment when the compass stops working, the moment when there's no way to tell exactly where you are, and no global positioning system to help you figure it out.
还有那种人，他们享受指南针停止工作的那一刻，享受那种无法准确判断位置、也没有全球定位系统来帮你搞清楚状况的时刻。
The good and bad thing now that everyone has GPS-- because in a way, it's certainly nice to know where you are. And it takes away a bit of the panic factor. It doesn't matter what part of the world you're in. But there is something lost there in always knowing exactly where you are.
现在每个人都有GPS，这既是好事也是坏事——因为在某种程度上，知道自己在哪里确实很好。它消除了一点恐慌感。无论你在世界的哪个角落都没关系。但总能确切地知道自己在哪里，其实也失去了一些东西。
Well, in a way, it's the opposite of adventure.
嗯，在某种程度上，这与冒险恰恰相反。
Sure, sure. And adventure, it becomes sort of an art when it comes to finding out or thinking of where you are and where you want to end up.
当然，当然。而冒险，当你去探索或思考身处何地以及你想去向何方时，它就变成了一种艺术。
On today's radio program, three stories, three people, three sets of maps. And what it's like to be lost, how we all struggle in that moment not to give ourselves over to fear, and, hopefully, try to enjoy it. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
在今天的广播节目中，有三个故事，三个人，三套地图。讲述迷路是什么感觉，讲述我们在那一刻如何努力不屈服于恐惧，并希望尝试享受它。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Act One of our program today, Ishtar Days, Arabian Nights. A man tries to lose himself completely, leave the places charted on maps. And what happens to you, and what you find when you try to leave the known world like this and succeed.
我们今天节目的第一幕，“伊什塔尔的日子，阿拉伯之夜”。一个男人试图让自己彻底迷失，离开地图上标出的地点。当你试图离开已知世界并成功做到这一点时，会发生什么，你会发现什么。
Act Two, The Game. Writer David Sedaris finds himself in a room full of people in a foreign city. He doesn't speak the language. He doesn't know anyone. And he has one simple, simple mission, a mission that you, yourself, may be capable of.
第二幕，“游戏”。作家大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）发现自己身处一个充满陌生人的外国城市。他不会说当地语言。他不认识任何人。他有一个简单、简单的任务，一个可能连你也有能力完成的任务。
Act Three, When You Can Snatch The Pebble From My Hand, Grasshopper, Then You Can Leave. One low-paid office worker tries to operate a global positioning apparatus on the map of her entire life. Stay with us, my friend.
第三幕，“当你能从我手中夺走这枚鹅卵石时，蚱蜢，你就可以离开了。”一位低薪办公室职员试图在自己整个人生的地图上操作一套全球定位系统。留下来陪我们，我的朋友。
Act One, Ishtar Days, Arabian Nights. Back when he was 21, John Bowe decided to visit a friend of his who was in the Peace Corps in Mali, in Africa. But he chose, I have to say, the most difficult possible route to get there. He decided to hitchhike across the Sahara Desert. And not just hitchhike, but hitchhike using a remote route 1,000 miles long that most hitchhikers avoid. He brought no special gear, carried a small bag filled mostly with books, one change of clothes. He wanted to go to places on the map with fewer and fewer roads.
第一幕，“伊什塔尔的日子，阿拉伯之夜”。21岁那年，约翰·鲍（John Bowe）决定去马里探望一个在和平队工作的朋友。但我不得不说，他选择了最艰难的路径。他决定搭车穿越撒哈拉沙漠。不仅是搭车，而且是搭车经过一条大多数搭车者避之不及的、长达1000英里的偏远路线。他没带任何特殊装备，只带了一个小包，里面装满了书和一套换洗衣服。他想去地图上那些道路越来越少的地方。
And I don't know. When you travel a lot, when you're traveling and just sort of drifting around, you spend a lot of time looking at the map. And you exoticize it. And you get this weird relationship to it, where you start just thinking, "Well, god, this was cool getting to this remote area. I bet  you it would be cooler to get to that area because it's that much more remote." You want to go off the map.
我不知道。当你经常旅行时，当你只是在四处漂泊时，你会花很多时间盯着地图。你会把它异域化。你和它建立了一种奇怪的关系，你开始想：“天哪，能到达这个偏远地区太酷了。我敢打赌，去那个地方会更酷，因为那里更偏远。”你想走出地图。
You want to go off the map? You want to go off the map, meaning you want to go off the area where the roads are on the map?
你想走出地图？你想走出地图的意思是，你想走出地图上标有道路的区域？
Right. But you want to go off the map in a more metaphorical sense, too. You want to get off of the grid of American life, the grid of the modern world. You want to get totally away from white people and American techno living that's defined world culture.
对。但你也想在更隐喻的意义上走出地图。你想脱离美国生活的网络，脱离现代世界的网络。你想要彻底远离白人和定义了世界文化的美国科技生活。
How easy or how hard was it to get off the map?
走出地图到底有多容易或多难？
Well, that's one of the really interesting things. You can hop on a plane from anywhere to anywhere, hop on another little plane or train or something else, and then walk 20 feet and be in the middle of nowhere, which is one of the weirdest things about the modern world. You could take a plane probably from New York to Manaus in Brazil, and take a boat, and immediately be lost in the middle of the rainforest. And it would take you all of a day to get there.
嗯，这是非常有趣的事情之一。你可以从任何地方搭飞机到任何地方，换乘另一架小飞机或火车或其他什么，然后走20英尺，就到了荒无人烟的地方，这是现代世界最奇怪的事情之一。你可以搭飞机从纽约到巴西的马瑙斯，乘船，立刻就会迷失在雨林深处。而且你只需要一天就能到达那里。
So the idea was to hitchhike across the Sahara Desert. And at first, I had had this idea because of my trusty Michelin map. They indicated that there was still a camel caravan that goes back and forth between southern Morocco and Timbuktu. And I kept asking people around, "Is there still a camel caravan that does this thing?" And people were kind of saying, yes, but only the people who were trying to sell me stuff, like, "Yeah, well, but you're going to need a lot of stuff for the journey. Why don't you buy this $300 worth of stuff?" So it's like, "Well, let me just make sure there's a caravan first."
所以我的想法是搭车穿越撒哈拉沙漠。起初，我有了这个想法是因为我那本值得信赖的米其林地图。地图上标示说，在摩洛哥南部和廷巴克图之间仍然有一支骆驼商队往返。我一直在问周围的人：“还有骆驼商队走这条路吗？”人们基本上回答说有，但只有那些想卖东西给我的人会说：“是啊，但你需要买很多东西才能踏上旅程。为什么不买这价值300美元的东西呢？”所以我就想：“好吧，让我先确认一下到底有没有商队。”
And then it's funny because, later, I found out about some German kid who had actually bought $1,000 worth of gear. And they said, "Oh yeah, just be here." They sold him a camel.
很有趣的是，后来我听说有个德国小孩真的买了价值1000美元的装备。他们对他说：“哦，没错，就在这等着。”然后卖给他一头骆驼。
And just wait here.
就在这儿等着。
Right. Be here on the second Sunday of every month, and the guys all come. You can start your journey then. So that seemed like it wasn't going to happen.
对。每个月的第二个星期天到这里，伙计们都会来。那时你就可以开始你的旅程了。所以看起来这事儿是不可能发生的。
So then I went to Algeria, down to Tamanrasset, which is about a third of the way across the desert. And then the plan was to hitchhike from there for the rest of the way. And it's weird flying over the desert because, at least this day, there were no clouds. You just see what it is you're getting into.
后来我去了阿尔及利亚，到了塔曼拉塞特，那是沙漠中途大约三分之一的地方。然后计划是从那里搭车走完剩下的路。飞越沙漠的感觉很奇怪，因为至少在那一天，天空没有云。你直接看到了你即将进入的是什么。
It's just sand. And maybe 30 miles over to the right of the plane, there might be a little oasis with just this little cluster of trees around it. And maybe 50 miles over to the left, there might be another one. But on the ground, that's 80 miles step by step in this 130 degree environment.
那只有沙子。或许在飞机的右侧30英里外，会有一个小绿洲，周围只有一小簇树木。或许在左侧50英里外，可能还有另一个。但在地面上，那意味着在130华氏度（约54摄氏度）的环境下，一步一步走过80英里。
So it's frightening.
所以这很可怕。
It's completely frightening. At that point, when you're still in the safety of an airplane, you're still on the map. You're still on the grid. But you definitely got the sense of the place that this is sort of the last stop on the grid.
这完全令人恐惧。那一刻，当你还在飞机的保护中时，你还在地图上。你还在这个网格内。但你确实感觉到，这个地方是网格的最后一站。
So I get to the outskirts of town. And of course, on the Michelin map--
所以我到了城郊。当然，在米其林地图上——
Now you're looking at the map.
你现在正在看地图。
I'm foraging. OK, here we go. Now the way the Michelin map marks roads is sort of arbitrary. In fact, you might even say capricious if your life depended on it, which, pretty soon, mine was going to. Because they make these things look like roads. But you don't realize until you get there, all they are are tracks in the sand.
我在搜寻。好，开始了。米其林地图标记道路的方式有些随意。事实上，如果你的生命取决于此——很快我的生命就要取决于此了——你甚至可以说这很任性。因为他们把这些东西画得像路一样。但直到你到达那里，你才会意识到，它们不过是沙地上的车辙。
Will the sand just blow over them, and then there's just nothing?
风会把沙子吹过它们，然后就什么都没有了？
Right. And there are dust storms frequently in this area. Tamanrasset is located in this place called the Hoggar, which they filmed a lot of commercials there. Whenever they're doing those commercials where someone says, "We went to the harshest environment on Earth to test--" whatever, DieHard batteries or whatever, that's where they go.
没错。而且这个地区经常有沙尘暴。塔曼拉塞特位于一个叫霍加尔的地方，那里拍过很多广告。每当他们拍摄那些有人说“我们去了地球上最严酷的环境来测试——”什么的广告时，无论是金霸王电池还是别的什么，他们都会去那里。
So anyway, so I got to the outer part of town. And I'm looking for what appears on the map to be a road. I've got my Michelin map, and I've got this faulty compass that it just would spin around and never be consistent.
总之，我到了城郊。我正在寻找地图上标示为道路的东西。我有我的米其林地图，还有一个会胡乱旋转、从不稳定的故障指南针。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, it was a really bad thing in a compass, right?
对，指南针这东西坏了真的很糟糕，对吧？
Describe the compass, please.
请描述一下那个指南针。
I can't remember much about it. It was a little cheap, $2 or $3 compass. This was the whole problem with the trip in so many ways is I just deliberately outfitted myself as poorly as possible.
我不记得关于它的太多细节了。那是一个廉价的、两三美元的指南针。这次旅行的整个问题在很多方面就是因为我故意把自己的装备准备得尽可能糟糕。
Anyway, so you're there.
好吧，所以你就在那里。
OK. So I'm there, and my compass is spinning around, not even wildly. It's just lazily spinning around. And I couldn't find any paved road. There were just these tire tracks radiating out in all directions from the town. There's no sense. There's no such thing as signs, saying, Denver, this way, Amarillo, that way.
好的。我就在那里，我的指南针在旋转，甚至不是狂乱地旋转。它只是懒洋洋地转着。我找不到任何铺设的道路。城外向四面八方放射出轮胎印。根本没有道理可言。根本没有那种写着“丹佛往这边，阿马里洛往那边”的指示牌。
I don't stop for a minute to think, "Well, this is kind of stupid." I have a liter of water, no provisions of any kind, and I'm talking about heading across 1,000 miles of desert. It just didn't enter my head the degree of stupidity of what I was doing.
我没有停下来想哪怕一分钟：“嗯，这有点蠢。”我有一升水，没有任何补给，却要横穿1000英里的沙漠。我当时脑子里根本没有意识到自己的行为有多蠢。
What was in your head? What were you thinking?
你脑子里在想什么？你当时在想什么？
You think you're being plucky rather than stupid. You're just looking at the goal of trying to get lost. Well, this is cool, but there's a city here. And you can always go further and further off the map. Oh, I bet you no one's ever done this.
你以为自己很勇敢，而不是很蠢。你只是盯着“想要迷失”这个目标。嗯，这很酷，但这里有一座城市。你可以走得离地图越来越远。哦，我敢打赌从来没人这么做过。
And in fact, there's something prideful about this is so stupid that no one else would dare to do this. You know what I mean? I bet you no one else has ever set off to cover 1,000 miles of desert with a quart of water in their pocket.
事实上，有一种傲慢感，觉得这太蠢了，以至于没人敢这么做。你知道我的意思吗？我敢打赌从来没有人揣着一夸脱水就出发去横穿1000英里的沙漠。
So I start walking. And again, it's 120 degrees, 125. It's heat waves everywhere. And you start walking down the road. And after a mile or two, a truck came along. So I hop in with this guy who turned out to be named Kurumi.
所以我开始走。同样，气温是120、125华氏度（约49-52摄氏度）。到处都是热浪。你开始沿着路走。走了一两英里，一辆卡车过来了。于是我跳上车，这个人名字叫库鲁米（Kurumi）。
And we're cruising along. It's so incredibly desolate. Every once in a while, a lizard would scurry across the road. But you got the sense that if you were out here in this heat, lost, you would be gone in a second.
我们沿着路行驶。这里极其荒凉。偶尔有一只蜥蜴从路上跑过。但你有一种感觉，如果你在这种高温下迷路了，你会瞬间丧命。
On my route, in the end, I found out stuff like if your car broke down from the heat, you were dead. You were just dead. Because there were so many days in a row when cars didn't go by at all. And the nomads would eventually come and pick your car clean. And you'd just be screwed.
最后我了解到，在我的路线上，如果你的车因为高温抛锚，你就死定了。你就死定了。因为这里有那么多天都没有车经过。游牧民最终会来把你的车搜刮一空。你就会彻底完蛋。
So I woke up in the morning, and we drove the rest of the way and got to this town, Timiawin, in the afternoon. And I walked over to what was the border post. And it was just the only place in town with a flag flying over it. And there was this guy who seemed to be the head official who was just loafing around on a mattress, on a bed stand, in the street, outside the border post, just sitting around in the shadows, picking his nails.
所以我在早上醒来，我们开了剩下的路，下午到了蒂米亚温镇。我走到边境哨所。那是镇上唯一挂着旗帜的地方。有个家伙看起来是最高长官，他正懒洋洋地躺在街上的床垫和床架上，就在边境哨所外，坐在阴凉处抠指甲。
And I said, "Hi." I'm all bright and shiny still, like, "Hi, can I get my passport stamped?" And he said, "Well, why don't you sit down?" So I said, "OK." So he was just sort of-- he was talking.
我说：“你好。”我那时还精神焕发，像是：“你好，能帮我的护照盖个章吗？”他说：“嗯，你为什么不坐下呢？”我说：“好的。”所以他只是在那儿——他在说话。
And finally, after a while, I said, "So do you think you could stamp my passport?" Or no, he said, actually, "OK, well, I'm ready to stamp your passport now. Will you hand it to me." And I looked around, and I looked around, and I couldn't find it. And I said, "Well, I think I must have given it to you, right? Didn't I give it to you before?" And he said, "Yeah, but I gave it back to you."
最后，过了一会儿，我说：“那么你觉得你能给我的护照盖个章吗？”或者不，他实际上说：“好的，好吧，我现在准备好盖章了。把护照给我。”我四处看了看，我又四处看了看，却找不到它。我说：“嗯，我想我一定给你了，对吧？我刚才没给你吗？”他说：“是啊，但我又还给你了。”
And I looked through my stuff again. And I said, "No, it must be somewhere. I think you have it because I don't have it." And he said, "Well, you better check again because if you don't find the damn thing, I can't stamp it, and you're going to be stuck here in Timiawin. And so I check one more time. And I'm getting completely sweaty.
我又检查了一遍我的东西。我说：“不，它一定在某处。我想在你那儿，因为我这儿没有。”他说：“好吧，你最好再查一遍，因为如果你找不到那该死的东西，我就不能盖章，你会被困在蒂米亚温。”于是我又查了一遍。我开始满头大汗。
And then he just starts smiling, and he lifts his leg. And it's been hiding under his leg the whole time. And he goes, "Ah, got you." That's your usual border post official behavior.
然后他突然开始笑了，他抬起他的腿。它一直藏在他的腿下面。他说：“啊，抓住你了。”这就是边境哨所官员的典型行为。
It's so interesting that if you are a border guard, there's one joke that you can enact on every customer. And that is the ancient joke. That joke dates back centuries. As long as there were people and borders, there could be that joke.
太有趣了，如果你是一名边境守卫，有一个笑话是你可以对每个顾客施展的。这就是那个古老的笑话。那个笑话可以追溯到几个世纪前。只要有人和边境，就会有那个笑话。
It's been passed down from a long line of prankster border guards. So he tells the joke, and then he says, "Ha, ha, ha." And we're good friends by then. And this Peugeot pickup truck arrives at the border post. And it's these Tuareg nomads, maybe six, seven, eight of them.
它是由一长串爱恶作剧的边境守卫传下来的。所以他讲了这个笑话，然后说：“哈哈哈。”到那时我们已经是好朋友了。然后一辆标致皮卡车开到了哨所。那是些图阿雷格游牧民，大约六、七、八个人。
Now explain a little bit about the Tuareg nomads.
现在，请解释一下关于图阿雷格游牧民的事。
OK, the Tuareg are really, really, really interesting. They call them "l'homme bleu" in French, which means "the blue men." And that's because they have these veils dyed of indigo. And the indigo gets into the pores of their skin. So even when they take off their veils, their skin has this purple tone. Some of the women tattoo their gums with some indigo thing, so that they have these weird purple gums. It's actually really cool looking.
好的，图阿雷格人真的、真的、真的很有趣。法语称他们为“l'homme bleu”，意思是“蓝人”。这是因为他们戴着染成靛蓝色的面纱。靛蓝色渗入了他们皮肤的毛孔。所以即使他们摘下面纱，皮肤也带有一种紫色。有些妇女用靛蓝色给牙龈纹身，所以她们有那种奇怪的紫色牙龈。这看起来真的很酷。
And they've been in the desert for centuries.
他们已经在沙漠里待了几个世纪了。
Yeah, they were controlling the whole salt trade back during the Medieval ages when Europe was getting their salt from Africa and stuff like that. And they made a hell of a lot of money. They lived very well. And they have this very regal bearing. They used to have their very own slave tribe called the Bella.
是的，在中世纪欧洲从非洲获取盐的时候，他们控制着整个盐贸易。他们赚了非常多的钱。他们生活得非常好。他们有一种非常高贵的气质。他们过去拥有自己的奴隶部落，叫贝拉人（Bella）。
And my friend, the friendly border post guy, started mumbling to them and pointing over to me. And then he came over to me, and he said, "Oh good, they're going to take you. I did you a favor. Get in the car." And so before I knew it, I was bounding out of town in the back of this pickup truck. Some of them were sitting in the back of it. They had a few big bags of figs or something back there.
我的朋友，那个友好的哨所官员，开始对他们嘟囔着什么，并指着我。然后他走过来对我说：“哦太好了，他们会带你走。我帮了你个忙。上车吧。”还没等我反应过来，我就在那辆皮卡车的后斗里颠簸着出城了。有些人坐在后斗里。他们还在后面放了几大袋无花果之类的东西。
So we go taking off. And after about 10 or 15 minutes, they stop the truck. And they whip out these mats, and they face Mecca, and they start praying. So you hang back and shut up. And then they finished up after a few minutes.
我们出发了。开了大约10到15分钟后，他们停下车。他们掏出垫子，面向麦加，开始祈祷。所以你就退后，闭嘴。几分钟后他们祈祷完了。
Then they piled back into the truck. And they realize, oh yeah, the truck doesn't start. We need to push truck to start. So they said, "Oh, will you help?" And I helped. So we push start the truck, and we get going again.
然后他们又爬回车里。然后他们意识到，哦对了，车打不着火了。我们需要推车启动。于是他们说：“哦，你能帮忙吗？”我帮忙了。我们推车启动了引擎，又出发了。
And then after another few minutes, they stopped the truck again. And I'm thinking, "I really wish that we would just haul ass and get to the next place." And they stop the truck, and they explain to me, "Oh yeah, this truck isn't so good." I'm like, "Oh, OK, well, that's no problem. It's just the Sahara Desert. It's no big deal."
几分钟后，他们又停了车。我想：“我真希望我们能赶紧开车去下一个地方。”他们停下车，跟我解释：“哦，这辆车不太好。”我说：“哦，好的，那没问题。这可是撒哈拉沙漠。没什么大不了的。”
So they get out their tools to fix the truck. And what they have is a beaten-up screwdriver and pliers. And they get under the truck, and I can hear this smashing around and grunting and swearing. At one point, they asked me to come down and help look underneath the car to see if I can help fix it. So I get underneath the car with them. And I realize that they don't have any more idea than I do what they're doing. They're just taking this screwdriver and this rusty, old pliers and fussing around with stuff.
于是他们拿出工具修理卡车。他们有的只是一把破螺丝刀和钳子。他们钻到车底下，我能听到那里面发出敲打声、咕哝声和咒骂声。有一次，他们叫我下去帮忙看看车底能不能修好。于是我跟着他们钻到车下。我意识到，他们根本不知道自己在做什么，和我一样。他们只是拿着那把螺丝刀和那把生锈的旧钳子，摆弄着零件。
So it started dawning on me, wow, this is a really bad place to be haphazard about this kind of stuff. And I didn't want to be a pain in the ass and start saying to them, "Gee, guys, this is scary." Here it is, it's about 170,000 degrees. And are you worried? That's what makes them be them. They don't worry.
所以我开始意识到，哇，在那种地方随随便便处理这种事可真糟糕。我不想讨人厌，开始对他们说：“天哪，伙计们，这很吓人。”现在的气温大约有17万度了。你们不担心吗？正是这种性格造就了他们。他们不担心。
And so you're kind of boiling over inside, but you don't want to be a baby about it. And I also just thought, it's not their business to look after me. Meanwhile, I'm trying like hell. I want to guzzle my water. I want to have a sip of water every minute. But I'm already 2/3 of the way through my water. So I have 1/3 of a liter left.
所以你内心快要沸腾了，但你不想表现得像个孩子。而且我当时也觉得，照顾我并不是他们的职责。同时，我拼命克制自己。我想猛灌我的水。我想每一分钟都喝一小口水。但我已经喝掉了2/3的水了。所以我只剩下1/3升了。
So we start up the truck again. And we go. And this is going on just for hours now. It gets into the afternoon. Again, this whole routine continues of just stopping the car every few minutes. We stop to pray, stop to fix the car, and I'm starting to go crazy. And I realize it really doesn't take long to go from a stressful situation to outright insanity. It only takes a little while. Because I start running out of water.
所以我们又发动了卡车。我们出发了。这种情况持续了好几个小时。时间到了下午。整个过程依然是每几分钟就停一次车。我们停下来祈祷，停下来修车，我开始抓狂了。我意识到从紧张局势到彻底疯狂真的不需要多长时间。只要一会儿就行。因为我的水快喝完了。
Oh, OK, I also should mention they had a baby with them. And the baby that they have is just sitting there, getting more and more and more sickly. And I start just focusing on this baby, as I'm watching it die. It looks like, for sure, this baby's within a day or two of death. And the baby is all wrapped up, so it can't move its hands or feet.
哦，对了，我得提一下，他们还带了一个婴儿。那个婴儿就坐在那儿，变得越来越病恹恹的。我开始盯着这个婴儿看，看着它死去。看起来这个婴儿肯定活不过一两天了。婴儿被包裹得严严实实，手脚都动不了。
And its poor face is just sitting there, sticking out its mom's back, looking at me. And its eyes are getting all crusty with all this goo. And all these flies are coming around and circling around its eyes, sucking at the goo. And these flies are just sucking and sucking. You just realize any available moisture in this environment gets sucked out.
它可怜的小脸就那样从妈妈的背上伸出来，看着我。它的眼睛上糊满了粘稠的胶状物。所有的苍蝇都聚拢过来，盘旋在它的眼睛周围，吸食那些胶状物。这些苍蝇只是不停地吸啊吸。你意识到在这个环境中任何可用的水分都会被吸走。
And that's what the nature of a desert is. And it just starts making you think any tenderness just gets sucked out. And you just start getting completely crazy, just thinking, that's what life is all about.
这就是沙漠的本质。这让你开始觉得任何温柔的东西都会被吸走。你开始变得彻底疯狂，只是心想，生命就是这么回事。
So one time we stop, and we're sitting there for half an hour fussing around. And these other nomads arrive seemingly out of nowhere on camel-back. And they say, "Hey guys, are you in trouble? Because for some money, we could probably help you out." And our guys yelled at them. And you could tell they were swearing, and they were getting into a fight.
所以有一次我们停下来，我们在那里摆弄了半个小时。那些其他的游牧民不知从哪儿骑着骆驼出现了。他们说：“嘿伙计们，你们遇上麻烦了吗？给我们点钱，或许我们可以帮帮你们。”我们车上的人对他们大吼。你可以听出他们在咒骂，他们吵了起来。
And then the new nomads, the new arrivals came up to me and said, "These guys look like losers. Where are you going?" I said, "Oh, I'm going to Aguel'hoc." And they said, "Well, for--" I don't know how many dollars, I think it was like $70-- "we'll give you a ride there."
然后新来的游牧民走到我跟前说：“这些人看起来像失败者。你要去哪儿？”我说：“哦，我要去阿盖尔霍克（Aguel'hoc）。”他们说：“好吧，给——”我不记得是多少钱了，我想大约是70美元——“我们载你过去。”
I guess I was tied-- I wanted to get the hell out of there and maybe live, for example. But I also felt tied to these guys, and I didn't want to ditch out on them. So I said, "No, no, thanks." And they said, "Well, OK, good luck." And they rode off, and I was just killing myself for not-- I just thought, "Oh god, you really should have gone with these guys because these Beverly Hillbillies Tuareg that you're with are really not happening."
我想我当时是……我只想离开这里，或者说，我还想活命。但我又觉得和这些人绑在一起，我不想抛弃他们。所以我说：“不，不，谢谢。”他们说：“好吧，祝你好运。”然后他们骑着骆驼走了，我真想杀了自己，因为我没——我心想：“天哪，你真应该跟他们走，因为你坐的这几位‘贝弗利山乡巴佬’图阿雷格人根本不靠谱。”
So we just keep having these breakdowns literally every 10 minutes. They say, "Well, I think we better just put up for the night here." So we break camp. And they whip all this stuff out of the back of the truck. And they have all these blankets. And they make a fire.
于是我们几乎每10分钟就抛锚一次。他们说：“嗯，我想我们最好在这儿过夜。”所以我们扎了营。他们把后斗里所有的东西都搬了出来。他们有这些毯子。他们生了一堆火。
And how are you feeling at this point? Because, after all, at this point, you have gotten your wish. You're off the grid. You're off of every kind of grid. You have left the map completely.
你当时感觉如何？因为毕竟，你现在愿望成真了。你离开了网络。你离开了所有的网络。你已经完全脱离了地图。
Right. It all came to a head right in this night. Because they all go to bed. And they're clustered up in this big ball together. And I'm all alone out there.
没错。这一切在那天晚上达到顶峰。因为他们全都睡着了。他们挤成一大团。而我一个人在外面。
And the second they're asleep and I'm all alone-- as I just sat there staring at the fire, and the wind is picking up and making all this noise. And you're incredibly lonely and incredibly alone, wandering around there, picking up the stuff, I realize there is not a sentient being, if you exclude these people who are asleep a few hundred yards over there, there is not a sentient being for hundreds of miles probably. I am the only one wandering around here. And it's just incredibly lonely.
就在他们睡着、我独自一人时——我坐在那儿盯着火看，风开始大起来，发出各种声响。你感到极其孤独，极其孑然一身，在那里走来走去，捡些东西，我意识到，除去那几百码外睡着的这些人，方圆几百英里内连一个有知觉的生命都没有。我是这里唯一走动的人。这真的非常孤独。
And that's around the time I heard this click. I don't know how well I can put this. It was just finally, I  all of a sudden got the sense of yeah, you are really off the map. You are so far off the map. You've never been this far off the map.
就在那时，我听到了那种“咔哒”声。我不知道该怎么形容。最终，我突然有一种感觉：没错，你真的走出地图了。你离地图这么远。你从来没有离地图这么远过。
And I started imagining, for example, what would happen if you died out here? You would just be gone forever. You would be swallowed up. There'd be no memory, no record whatsoever of whatever had happened to you. No one who ever knew you would be able to find you. You wanted to lose control, and now you've lost control.
我开始想象，比如，如果你死在这里会怎样？你会永远消失。你会像被吞没一样。不会有任何记忆，不会有任何记录证明你曾经发生过什么。任何认识你的人都找不到你。你想失去控制，现在你彻底失去了控制。
But you just catch this little click that the whole universe makes. It's this silent, little chick that says, "Oh, you've passed the point of no return." There are no words you could use to describe what that feeling is like of, oh, I'm so naive, oh, the world is so cruel, oh my god, this is what you wanted, this is what you've got.
但你会捕捉到整个宇宙发出的那一点点微小的咔哒声。那是沉默的一声小咔哒，仿佛在说：“哦，你已经过了不归点。”你找不到任何词汇来形容那种感觉，噢，我太天真了，噢，世界太残酷了，噢天哪，这就是你想要的，这就是你得到的。
Oh, I could die here.
噢，我可能会死在这里。
I could die here.
我可能会死在这里。
I could die today, now. It could happen right now.
我今天可能就会死，就在现在。可能现在就会发生。
And so it's just that feeling of you played yourself. You did it. You kept going further and further out on a limb, and now it just broke. And you're like Wile E. Coyote. You're above the two-mile-deep chasm, just waiting to fall.
所以那种感觉就是，你自己坑了自己。你做到了。你一直不断地向外延伸，最后那根树枝断了。你就像威利狼（Wile E. Coyote）。你站在两英里深的裂谷上方，等着坠落。
I don't know. I think there just was this very arrogant taunt of saying, "Well, dear world, you have to kill me or tell me what's interesting about you." Or something.
我不知道。我觉得当时有一种非常傲慢的嘲讽，仿佛在说：“嗯，亲爱的世界，要么杀了我，要么告诉我你有什么好玩的。”之类的。
Yeah, give me something to believe in, or kill me.
是的，给我一点信仰，不然就杀了我。
Right. Dear God, give me what I want, or I'm going to go shop elsewhere. And you don't do that. That's really arrogant. You don't demand answers like that and just get them. And I think the answer that I got was, "No, thanks. We're just going to make you profoundly unpleasant. I'm just going to scare the hell out of you, and then we'll let you live."
没错。天哪，给我想要的，不然我就去别处购物了。你不能这么做。那太傲慢了。你不能那样要求答案，然后就能直接得到。而我认为我得到的答案是：“不，谢谢。我们只会让你极其难受。我会吓死你，然后让你活着。”
John Bowe is now a writer in New York. After a day with the Tuareg nomads, a truck came by, which put him in motion toward Mali and, much later, towards home.
约翰·鲍现在是纽约的一名作家。和图阿雷格游牧民度过一天后，一辆卡车路过，载着他向马里方向前进，许久之后，他回到了家。
[MUSIC - "LET'S GET LOST" BY CHET BAKER]
[音乐 - 切特·贝克（Chet Baker）的《让我们迷失》（Let's Get Lost）]
Coming up, David Sedaris plays a game pretending he's lost, plays it over and over, plays, and plays, and plays. Until one day, he experiences the real thing and does not much like it. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·塞达里斯玩了一个假装自己迷路的游戏，一遍又一遍地玩，玩啊玩，玩啊玩。直到有一天，他经历了真正的迷路，却觉得一点都不好玩。国际公共广播电台将在稍后节目继续时播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of people to bring you stories on that theme. Today's program, You Are Here, stories of people getting lost and how people react to getting lost. Some people seek it. Some people are scared by it. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Game.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请不同的人为你带来关于这个主题的故事。今天的节目主题是“你在这里”，讲述人们迷路以及人们在迷路时的反应。有些人寻求迷路。有些人因迷路而感到恐惧。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“游戏”。
Yes, it can be frightening to get lost. But what if you could adapt the thrill of getting lost, the pleasure of getting lost to safe parameters? Confine it, just get a little, tiny bit lost? Is that even possible? Or is that playing with fire, and you're sure to get burned? Well, writer David Sedaris has made the attempt himself. And so, of course, you don't have to.
是的，迷路可能会让人恐惧。但如果你能调整迷路的刺激感，把迷路的快乐放在安全的参数范围内呢？限制它，只迷失一丁点儿？这可能吗？还是说那是在玩火，你肯定会被烧伤？嗯，作家大卫·塞达里斯自己尝试过了。所以当然，你就不必尝试了。
Whenever I find myself in a strange or unusual situation, I like to play this little game. To begin with, I have to pretend that a part of my brain has been asleep for exactly one year, while the rest of my body has been answering the phone and carrying on as usual. Now I've suddenly woken up, and I can't leave this spot until I gathered clues and figured out exactly where I am. The game is generally played during those moments when people tend to pinch themselves as a reminder of the dramatic turn their life has taken.
每当我发现自己处于一种陌生或不寻常的境地时，我都喜欢玩这个小游戏。首先，我必须假装我大脑的一部分已经沉睡了整整一年，而我身体的其他部分一直在正常接听电话和生活。现在我突然醒了，在我收集线索并搞清楚我到底在哪儿之前，我不能离开这个点。这个游戏通常是在人们想要掐自己一下，提醒自己人生发生了戏剧性转折的那一刻玩的。
An example from a trip given as a reward for my college graduation. I'm standing in a grim cinder block building, looking out over rows of porcelain toilets arranged across the concrete floor much like the seats in a movie theater. Men are sitting on these toilets, some of them talking or reading the newspaper and others just staring ahead. There's a 1/2 inch of water on the floor, and a bottle cap floats by followed by a plastic spoon.
一个例子是毕业奖励的旅行。我站在一栋冷冰冰的混凝土建筑里，俯瞰着地面上一排排像电影院座位一样排列的瓷制马桶。男人们坐在马桶上，有的在聊天或看报纸，有的只是直视前方。地板上有半英寸的水，一个瓶盖漂过，后面跟着一个塑料勺子。
I probably came in to use the urinal, but rather than get my shoes wet, I'm deciding that maybe I'll just hold it and try someplace else. I turn to leave, but I can't. The game has begun. And now, according to the rules, I'll have to stay in this bathroom until I either hear or read the name of this particular town.
我大概是进来用小便池的，但与其弄湿鞋子，我决定还是憋着去别处试试。我转过身想离开，但走不了。游戏已经开始了。现在，按照规则，我必须待在这个厕所里，直到我听到或读到这个特定小镇的名字。
At this point, the exercise becomes more of an obsession than a game. It's not particularly fun to stand on your toes in an unventilated public toilet. But I'm powerless to leave until the person I was one year ago has figured out where he is. "OK," I think, "let's break this down."
此时，这种练习与其说是游戏，不如说是一种强迫症。站在不通风的公共厕所里垫着脚并不怎么好玩。但在我一年前的那部分自我搞清楚他身在何处之前，我无力离开。“好的，”我想，“我们来分析一下。”
The people in the bathroom are speaking Spanish. They appear to be Mexican, but that's not good enough. They could be-- I don't know-- on vacation or something. In the far corner of the room, a teenage boy is playing a radio, and that's probably my best bet. I'm hoping that sooner or later the announcer might mention the call letters, adding that his is the number one station in wherever it is I happen to be.
厕所里的人在说西班牙语。他们看起来像是墨西哥人，但这还不够。他们可能——我不知道——在度假什么的。房间的最角落里，一个十几岁的男孩正在放收音机，那可能是我的最佳筹码。我希望迟早播音员会提到电台呼号，并补充说这是他所在的那个地方排名第一的电台。
Unfortunately, the radio is currently broadcasting what appears to be the Spanish equivalent of "American Pie." I'm waiting and waiting for the song to end when a man enters the bathroom carrying a shopping bag. I read the name of the store followed by the words "Mexico City." And only then am I free to rush outdoors, where my traveling companion says, "Jesus, what took you so long?"
不幸的是，收音机目前正在播放听起来像是西班牙语版的《美国派》（American Pie）。我等啊等，等着歌结束，这时一个男人提着购物袋走进厕所。我读到了店名，后面跟着“墨西哥城”这几个字。直到这时，我才自由地冲出室外，我的旅伴说：“天哪，你怎么去了那么久？”
I take pleasure in the game partly because my life so rarely takes a dramatic turn. To put it mildly, I am a reluctant traveler, my preferred phrase being, "You go ahead. Someone needs to stay behind and take care of the cat." My hatred of travel is partially what makes the game so rewarding. I like the dreamlike quality of waking up in a strange place and the clinical way in which I'm forced to view my surroundings.
我喜欢这个游戏，部分是因为我的人生很少有戏剧性的转折。说得委婉点，我是个不情愿的旅行者，我的口头禅是：“你们去吧。总得有人留下来照顾猫。”我对旅行的憎恨部分原因正是这个游戏变得如此值得玩的原因。我喜欢在陌生地方醒来的那种梦幻感，以及我被迫以一种临床视角审视周围环境的方式。
The game is never arranged in advance. It just kicks in on its own, usually prompted by a combination of visual elements I can only define as astonishing. When played in pleasant circumstances, the effect is narcotic.
游戏从不提前安排。它会自行启动，通常是由一些我只能定义为“惊人”的视觉元素组合激发的。在愉快的情况下玩这个游戏，效果就像麻醉剂。
Another example. I come to, and I find myself sitting in a cafe, admiring a corkscrew made out of a deer's foot. Something suggests that it probably belongs to me. I've always loved functional taxidermy, as it downplays the sportier aspects of hunting and makes shooting animals seem comically practical. I imagine someone rising at dawn and buttoning up his camouflaged vest. His corkscrew has broken, so now he'll have to go out and kill a deer.
再举个例子。我醒来，发现自己坐在一家咖啡馆里，正欣赏着一个由鹿蹄制成的开瓶器。某些迹象表明它大概属于我。我一直喜欢实用的动物标本，因为它淡化了狩猎中运动的一面，让射杀动物看起来颇具喜剧色彩地实用。我想象有人在黎明起床，扣上他的迷彩背心。他的开瓶器坏了，所以现在他得出去杀一只鹿。
The object sits before me on a table alongside a shaver made from an antler. A waitress appears, saying, "You must have been over to Terry's place down by the river. Oh, he makes such lovely things." The woman speaks English in an accent I can't quite identify except to say that she probably recognizes the authority of a queen. She sets down the cup of tea I had apparently ordered, and I thank her.
这个物体摆在我面前的桌子上，旁边还有一个由鹿角制成的剃须刀。一位女服务员走过来说：“你一定去了河边的特里家。哦，他做的东西太可爱了。”这个女人说英语的口音我认不出来，只能说她大概承认女王的权威。她放下我显然点的那杯茶，我谢谢她。
At the next table, an infant is crying, and I watch as a young mother fills the baby's bottle with Coca-Cola. In looking from one person to the next, I realize that I have the best teeth in the room. I have never in my life been in such a situation, and I proceed to take full advantage of it. I'm grinning like an idiot when my boyfriend, Hugh, enters the room and takes a seat beside me.
邻桌有一个婴儿在哭，我看着一位年轻的妈妈往婴儿瓶子里倒可口可乐。从一个人看着另一个人，我意识到我是屋子里牙齿最好的人。我这辈子从未处于过这种境地，我决定充分利用这一点。当我男朋友休（Hugh）走进房间并在我旁边坐下时，我正笑得像个白痴。
He's not in on the game. But even if he were, it wouldn't do me any good. It's against the rules to ask anyone where I am or to lead the conversation in that general direction.
他没参与这个游戏。但即使他参与了也没用。规则禁止向任何人询问我在哪儿，或引导谈话朝那个方向发展。
It's times like this when I notice the difference between the way people talk in real life and the way they speak in the sorts of movies that heap on the exposition in order to cut to the chase. The movie version-- "Christ, BW, we've been waiting on the corner of 8th Avenue and 51st Street in the Hell's Kitchen section of New York City for over an hour and 45 minutes." Real-life version-- "I'm tired."
正是这种时候，我注意到了人们现实生活中的谈话方式，与那种为了推进剧情而堆砌背景信息的电影中谈话方式的区别。电影版——“天哪，BW，我们在纽约市地狱厨房区第八大道和51街的拐角处等了整整一小时45分钟了。”现实版——“我累了。”
Hugh mentions a pair of taxidermied owls he's seen in a little shop down the street. This eliminates any doubt that we might possibly be in the United States, a country which forbids the mounting of its owls regardless of the circumstances. Even if one drops dead of a heart attack, you're not allowed to stuff it with straw or turn it into something useful like a desk clock. "You can buy owls here in Scotland," he says. "The only problem would be getting it back home." He lifts his tea cup, adding, "Is there something wrong with your mouth?"
休提到了他在街上的小店里看到的一对猫头鹰标本。这消除了我们可能身处美国的任何疑虑，因为美国禁止制作猫头鹰标本，无论情况如何。即使它因心脏病发作死了，你也不允许用草填充它，或把它变成像台钟那样有用的东西。“你可以在苏格兰买到猫头鹰，”他说，“唯一的问题是如何把它带回国。”他举起茶杯，补充道：“你的嘴巴怎么了吗？”
My smile fades. He said the magic word, "Scotland," though I wish he hadn't because now the game is half over. I'm enjoying this little cafe with its views of the darkening street. And although Hugh's presence has ended my brief reign as holder of the room's finest teeth, I want to take my time and play at a leisurely pace.
我的笑容消失了。他说了那个神奇的词，“苏格兰”，虽然我希望他没说，因为现在游戏玩了一半了。我正在享受这家咖啡馆，欣赏着黑暗街道的景色。虽然休的出现终结了我作为屋里牙齿最好的人的短暂统治，但我还想慢慢玩，享受那种悠闲的节奏。
We sit for a few minutes before the waitress swoops in and formally ends the game. "So," she says, "are you enjoying yourself here in Pitlochry?" It's a conspiracy. She and Hugh get to talking and within two minutes, she's mentioned the street, the country, everything, but the compass points. Check, please.
我们坐了几分钟，女服务员走过来，正式结束了游戏。“那么，”她说，“你在皮特洛赫里玩得开心吗？”这简直是勾结。她和休聊了起来，两分钟内，她提到了街道、国家，除了指南针方向外什么都说了。结账吧。
I've played the game since my first trip to summer camp. And in all that time, I never acknowledged its inherent safety net. While the David I pretended to be was shocked to find himself in Rome, Valencia, or Gastonia, the David I was at the time knew very well that he was in Italy, or Spain, or spending two weeks at Camp Cheerio. It's basically just a simulation exercise like one of those emergency procedure drills enacted by astronauts in training. I never realized what a joke it was until recently, when I found myself playing the game for real, and I panicked. It went like this.
我从第一次参加夏令营以来就一直在玩这个游戏。在所有这些时间里，我从未承认它固有的安全网。虽然我假装的那个大卫（David）对发现自己身处罗马、瓦伦西亚或加斯托尼亚感到震惊，但当时的我非常清楚自己身在意大利、西班牙，或者是在切里奥夏令营度过两周。它本质上只是一个模拟练习，就像宇航员训练时进行的那些紧急程序演习一样。直到最近，当我发现自己在玩一场真正的游戏时，我才意识到这有多可笑，而且我恐慌了。情况是这样的。
I'm in a grocery store, but aside from the plastic wrapped meats and vegetables, I'm not finding much that I can hold onto. It isn't that they're selling anything remarkably exotic. It's just that I can't read the labels. Here, each word includes no less than 15 letters. And every box and can seems to picture a strapping family unit, smiling broadly for no apparent reason.
我正在一家杂货店里，但除了塑料包裹的肉类和蔬菜外，我找不到太多能让我把握的东西。并不是他们卖的东西特别异国情调。只是我看不懂标签。在这里，每个单词都不少于15个字母。每个盒子和罐子似乎都印着一个充满活力的家庭，无缘无故地大笑。
It's 6 o'clock in the evening, and the store is crowded with well-dressed professionals on their way home from work. I'm standing in what smells to be the soap and shampoo section when a young woman approaches, pushing her shopping cart with her chin. Her shiny, chestnut-colored hair hangs in front of her face until she flicks her head, and the hair resettles about her shoulders. The woman wears a knee-length skirt and a knit, sleeveless blouse and has no arms whatsoever. She stands beside me, and then she slips off one of her loafers and reaches for a plastic bottle with her bare foot.
傍晚6点，店里挤满了下班回家、衣着光鲜的专业人士。我正站在闻起来像是肥皂和洗发水区的地方，一个年轻女子走过来，用下巴推着购物车。她闪亮的栗色头发垂在脸前，直到她甩了甩头，头发重新落在肩上。那个女人穿着及膝裙和针织无袖衫，根本没有胳膊。她站在我旁边，然后脱掉一只平底鞋，用光脚去拿一瓶塑料瓶。
There is no awkwardness to this moment. Her leg moves gracefully, and her foot works no differently than a hand. It's even decorated like a hand. Her nails are painted, and there's a gold bracelet around her ankle. And she's wearing a wedding band on one of her toes.
这一刻并没有任何尴尬。她的腿动得很优雅，脚的工作方式和手没什么两样。它甚至被装饰得像手一样。指甲油得漂漂亮亮的，脚踝上戴着金手链。脚趾上还戴着婚戒。
I'm curious as to how she might pay for her groceries, but we get separated at the registers. I realize then that the more important question is how I will pay for my groceries. I understand neither the currency nor the language, so my best bet will be to hand the cashier the largest bill I've got and hope that's enough to cover it. There are only a few items in my basket, a tube of what is hopefully toothpaste, but possibly a vaginal lubricant, a cigarette lighter in the shape of a genie, and five tins of cat food.
我很好奇她会怎么付钱，但在收银台我们分开了。我那时意识到一个更重要的问题，就是我该怎么付钱。我既不懂货币也不懂语言，所以我最好的办法就是把手里最大面值的钞票给收银员，希望足够覆盖费用。我的篮子里只有几件东西：一支希望是牙膏但可能是阴道润滑剂的管状物，一个精灵形状的打火机，还有五罐猫粮。
I've emptied my items onto the belt when I notice that everyone around me is caring an empty canvas sack in which to pack their groceries. I, myself, have no sack. The cashier offers me no plastic bag. And so after paying with my large bill, I stuff the lighter, cat food, and toothpaste into my pockets, pretending that this is the way I prefer to carry my groceries home from the store.
我清空了传送带上的东西，这时我注意到周围每个人都提着一个空的帆布袋来装杂货。我自己没有袋子。收银员没给我塑料袋。于是，在支付了大额钞票后，我把打火机、猫粮和牙膏塞进兜里，假装这就是我偏好的杂货拎回家的方式。
It's difficult to walk properly with both my front and back pockets stuffed tight with cat food. I'm ready to return to my hotel, but then I notice the armless woman walk out with a bag held between her teeth. And then the game begins in earnest.
兜里塞满了猫粮，走路姿势很难保持正常。我准备回酒店，但我注意到那个没胳膊的女人嘴里叼着个袋子走出去了。于是游戏正式开始了。
I'm looking up and down the busy street, hoping to read the name of this city on a shop window, when I suddenly realize, I have absolutely no idea where I am. I'd recognize the name if I saw it written down. But other than that, I haven't got a clue. My first instinct is to throw up my hands and scream like a girl. And it is only with great effort that I manage to silence myself.
我在这条繁忙的街道上四处张望，希望能从商店橱窗读出这个城市的名字，这时我突然意识到，我完全不知道自己在哪儿。如果我看到名字写下来，我会认出来的。但除此之外，我毫无头绪。我的第一个本能是举起手像个女孩一样尖叫。我费了很大劲才让自己闭嘴。
I know for a fact that I am in Germany, but I honestly can't remember where in Germany. I'm here on a promotional tour, eight cities over the course of a week. Monday was Berlin. Tuesday was Stuttgart, followed by Mannheim. But where am I today?
我确定自己身处德国，但我真的记不起是在德国的哪个地方了。我来这儿进行巡回宣传，一周内要跑八个城市。周一在柏林。周二在斯图加特，然后是曼海姆。但今天我在哪儿？
It's a half-hour walk back to my hotel, but that doesn't worry me. I can locate the hotel. I just can't locate myself. Neither can I leave this block and return to the hotel before the game is finished. And this presents a problem as my hosts will be picking me up in a little less than an hour.
回酒店要走半小时，但我不担心。我能找到酒店。只是找不到我自己。我也不能在游戏结束前离开这个街区回酒店。这造成了一个问题，因为我的主人再过不到一小时就会来接我。
Yes, it's just a game. And yes, it's just a rule. But if, like me, you're just a compulsive maniac, you know that games and rules are everything.
是的，这只是个游戏。是的，这只是个规则。但如果你像我一样是个强迫症狂人，你就知道游戏和规则就是一切。
I'm thinking I might return to the grocery store and see if they've got a magazine rack. But no, I can't walk in because my pockets are full of cat food, and they might very reasonably mistake me for a shoplifter. A shoe store, a bakery, a record shop. One stand selling flowers and another selling sausages. Through their windows, I see nothing that can help me. I tell myself that sooner or later, a bus will come along, bearing the city's name in bright, easy-to-read letters. 20 minutes pass before I'm able to narrow things down a bit and deduce that wherever I am, it is definitely not on a bus route.
我想我可能会回到杂货店看看他们有没有杂志架。但不行，我进不去，因为我兜里装满了猫粮，他们很可能会合理地把我误认为小偷。鞋店、面包店、唱片店。一个卖花的摊位，另一个卖香肠。透过橱窗，我什么有用的信息也没看到。我告诉自己，迟早会有一辆公车经过，上面会用明亮、易读的字体写着城市名。过了20分钟，我才缩小了范围，推断出无论我在哪儿，这里绝对不在公车路线上。
I'm racing up and down the block, desperate for evidence, when I suddenly start thinking about Hugh Downs. I'd seen him once when we shared a flight from Phoenix to New York. He moved through the airport minding his own business, and I'd followed along behind him, watching as people rushed forward to say, "Hey, you're Hugh Downs. What are you doing in Phoenix, Arizona?" He did nothing to provoke this response and was courteous even when the goons at the x-ray scanner stopped him for an autograph, saying, "Well, if it isn't Hugh Downs, host of 20/20. What are you doing here in Phoenix?"
我在街区上跑来跑去，绝望地寻找证据，这时我突然想到了休·唐斯（Hugh Downs）。有一次我们同乘飞机从凤凰城飞往纽约时见过他。他在机场里各忙各的，我跟在他后面，看着人们冲上来问：“嘿，你是休·唐斯。你在亚利桑那州凤凰城做什么？”他什么也没做来引起这种反应，即使当X光扫描仪的笨蛋拦下他要签名时，他也很有礼貌，他们说：“哟，这不是休·唐斯吗，《20/20》的主持人。你在凤凰城做什么？”
For him, the game would be a snap. Should he develop Alzheimer's disease, all he'd have to do is walk out the door and willing strangers would tell him everything he needed to know. "You used to host The Today Show." "You're Hugh Downs. What are you doing here in--" fill in the blank. Due to his television celebrity, he benefits from what I now refer to as The Downs Syndrome.
对他来说，这个游戏轻而易举。如果他患上阿尔茨海默症，他所要做的就是走出家门，热心的陌生人就会告诉他想知道的一切。“你以前主持过《今日秀》（The Today Show）。”“你是休·唐斯。你在——做什么呢？”（填空）。由于他的电视名人身份，他受益于我现在称为“唐斯综合征”（The Downs Syndrome）的东西。
The man couldn't get lost if his life depended on it. In my mind, it was now me against him. And he had it easy. This sense of competition spurred me on, and, within minutes, I was rifling through the corner trash can, cursing Hugh Downs' name with every used Kleenex and disposable diaper.
如果生命取决于此，那个男人也绝不会迷路。在我心目中，这成了我和他之间的较量。而他却赢得轻而易举。这种竞争感鞭策着我，几分钟内，我就在街角的垃圾桶里翻找，每翻出一个用过的纸巾或尿布，就诅咒休·唐斯的名字。
Eventually, amidst the crumpled flyers and crushed paper cups, I came across a discarded ATM receipt. And there it was. There I was, safe and victorious. I retracted all the mean things I'd thought about Hugh Downs, took a moment to gloat, and then, arm in arm with the person I used to be, I walked back to my hotel room in the German city of Cologne.
最终，在揉皱的传单和压扁的纸杯中，我翻出了一张丢弃的ATM收据。就是它。我就在那里，安全且胜利了。我收回了关于休·唐斯的所有刻薄想法，花了一点时间窃喜，然后，挽着曾经的自己，走回了我在德国城市科隆的酒店房间。
Writer David Sedaris.
作家大卫·塞达里斯。
[MUSIC - "FLY INTO MYSTERY" BY JONATHAN RICHMAN AND THE MODERN LOVERS]
[音乐 - 乔纳森·里奇曼（Jonathan Richman）和现代恋人乐队（The Modern Lovers）的《飞入神秘》（Fly Into Mystery）]
Act Three, Snatch The Pebble From My Hand, Grasshopper, And Then You Can Leave. There's a class of people in certain professional fields called assistant. I had a friend who was the assistant for NPR's Daniel Schorr, then the assistant for NPR's Nina Totenberg, then for a New Yorker magazine writer, then for a New Yorker editor. And in all of those years, as this went by, as she watched her 20s ebb away, it seemed impossible to her to ever break the yoke of assistant-hood. The skills to do the job of assistant-- answering phones, faxing beautifully, were entirely different than the skills needed for the jobs that all assistants really want, that is, those of the people that they assist. It's a trap.
第三幕，“从我手中夺走这枚鹅卵石，蚱蜢，然后你就可以离开了。”在某些专业领域有一种职员叫助理。我有一个朋友，她曾是NPR（美国公共广播电台）丹尼尔·肖尔（Daniel Schorr）的助理，然后是NPR尼娜·托滕伯格（Nina Totenberg）的助理，接着是《纽约客》杂志作家助理，后来又成了《纽约客》编辑的助理。在那些年里，随着时光流逝，随着她眼看着自己的20多岁渐渐远去，对她来说，要打破助理职位的枷锁似乎是不可能的。助理工作的技能——接电话、完美传真，与助理们真正想要的工作——也就是他们所辅助的那些人的工作——所需的技能完全不同。这是个陷阱。
Nicole Graev is an assistant to an editor at a publishing house at Simon & Schuster. She finds herself lacking a map to her own life because of her very assistant-hood. She needs a map to where she's going. She's lost. She does not know where she is, and she is not happy about all this. And she set out to find some map to give her a sense, a sense of "You are here."
妮可·格雷夫（Nicole Graev）是西蒙与舒斯特出版社（Simon & Schuster）的一名编辑助理。因为她的助理身份，她发现自己缺乏一份指引自己人生的地图。她需要一份通向未来的地图。她迷失了。她不知道自己在哪里，她对这一切感到不快乐。于是她出发去寻找地图，给自己一种“你在这里”的感觉。
When I was in school, I majored in what is arguably the least useful subject in the English-speaking world, English. And yet, I always saw my future as this vast, sunny stretch of infinite possibilities. And the night before I started my first job as an editorial assistant at Simon & Schuster, I couldn't fall asleep. In just hours, I'd be hitting it, that glorious horizon I'd been speeding towards my entire life.
在学校时，我主修了英语，这可以说是英语世界中最无用的专业。然而，我总是把我的未来看作是一段广阔、晴朗且无限可能的延伸。在西蒙与舒斯特出版社开始第一份编辑助理工作的前一天晚上，我辗转反侧。只要几个小时，我就能触碰到了，那道我一生都在努力奔向的光辉地平线。
The thing about the wide and limitless future that no one warns you about, once you get there, it ceases to be wide and limitless. The millions of possibilities suddenly crystallize into one choice, one present, one single five-by-five cubicle. With one swift move, I'd narrowed a world of options down to four foam-core walls and a file cabinet, though I often get to leave to visit the photocopier.
关于广阔且无限未来的问题是，没人会警告你，一旦你到达那里，它就不再广阔且无限了。数百万的可能性突然结晶成一个选择、一个当下、一个五英尺乘五英尺的隔间。通过这一个轻快的举动，我把世界的各种选项缩小到了四面泡沫板墙和一个文件柜，尽管我经常能借机溜出去访问复印机。
In school it's always clear how to succeed. As long as you work hard, get good grades, you move ahead. But in this job, I felt like I'd hit a dead end. The gap between assistants and editors seemed unbridgeable. We never saw them cut deals, never watched them make decisions, never heard them talking to their authors. On my one-year anniversary at Simon & Schuster, I received a commemorative pen which I used the next day to clear a paper jam.
在学校里，如何成功总是很明确。只要努力工作、取得好成绩，你就会前进。但在工作中，我觉得自己走进了死胡同。助理和编辑之间的鸿沟似乎无法逾越。我们从没见过他们做交易，没看过他们做决策，没听过他们和作者交谈。在西蒙与舒斯特出版社工作一周年纪念日，我收到了一支纪念笔，第二天我就用它清理了卡纸。
I decided to track down some of the people who'd started off right where I am now, in the same job, the same company, same building, same floor, to see if anything became of them, if this job actually leads anywhere. They could show me where I was headed and give me the map I wanted to get myself there. I began just 20 steps from my own desk. Michael Korda, Simon & Schuster's editor-in-chief, started here as an editorial assistant in 1958, just 41 short years ago.
我决定追踪那些从我现在的位置起步的人——做着同样的工作、在同一家公司、同一栋楼、同一个楼层——来看看他们后来怎么样了，如果这份工作真的能通向任何地方的话。他们能向我展示我要去往何处，并给我想要的地图来带我到达那里。我从距离自己办公桌仅20步远的地方开始了追踪。迈克尔·科达（Michael Korda），西蒙与舒斯特出版社的总编辑，1958年就在这儿开始了编辑助理工作，那不过是41年前的事。
Well, I'm not sure that I'm the very best example of what you're talking about. I came into book publishing without any particular impulse to be in book publishing. I'd fought in the Hungarian Revolution in 1956, having left Oxford to do so.
嗯，我不确定你谈论的那种情况，我是否是最好的例子。我进入图书出版业时并没有什么特别的冲动。我曾参加过1956年的匈牙利革命，为此离开了牛津大学。
Michael went on to list the multitude of ways in which I'm nothing like him. His father won Academy Awards. His mother and aunt were famous actresses in Europe. His uncle directed his first feature film at the age of 20. At 20, my dad was pumping gas on the outskirts of Syracuse.
迈克尔接着列举了种种我与他完全不同之处。他的父亲赢得过奥斯卡奖。他的母亲和姨妈是欧洲著名的女演员。他的叔叔在20岁时就执导了自己的第一部剧情片。20岁时，我的父亲正在雪城郊区给人加油。
Fortunately for me, there were a number of things that were in my favor. I am a stupendously fast reader and always have been. I can read in at least three languages fluently and two languages with a little bit more difficulty.
对我来说幸运的是，确实有一些因素对我有利。我是一个极其快速的阅读者，一直都是。我至少能流利地阅读三种语言，用另外两种语言阅读也相对没那么困难。
Where exactly did foreign languages fit into my position anyway? As Michael talked more about his time as an assistant, it dawned on me. His job hadn't been the same one as mine at all. He was an assistant back in the days when American companies still had a job called "secretary." Now in publishing, as in so many businesses, there aren't many secretaries. Instead, they hire college grads like me, pay us less money, wave vague promises in front of us, and trick us by calling us assistants, a misleading title that makes it seem like we're actually on the map, heading somewhere.
外语到底是怎么契合我的职位的？随着迈克尔更多地谈论他担任助理的时光，我明白了。他的工作根本和我的一样。他担任助理时，美国公司还有一个叫“秘书”的职位。现在的出版业，像许多其他业务一样，没有多少秘书了。相反，他们聘请像我这样的大学毕业生，支付更少的薪水，在我们面前挥舞着模糊的承诺，并用“助理”这个词诱骗我们，这是一个误导性的头衔，让我们看起来好像真的在地图上，在向某个地方前进。
I pressed Michael for advice, and he gave me a few of the usual suggestions. Work hard, read a lot, maintain a sense of purpose. "But the most important thing I could do as an assistant," he told me, "was to find some way to make myself stand out."
我向迈克尔索要建议，他给了我几个常用的建议。努力工作、多读书、保持目标感。“但作为助理我能做的最重要的事情，”他告诉我，“就是想方设法让自己脱颖而出。”
In my experience, with very few exceptions-- I am, as it happens, one of the exceptions-- the one thing that most editors don't want to do is edit. It's not nearly as conducive to a successful career as having lunch out with important agents or going to meetings where you get noticed. So my guess is that almost any editor would just as soon leave the editing to somebody else if he or she were certain that the editing would be done in a way not to cause problems. That, to me, is the way ahead for any editorial assistant.
根据我的经验，除了极少数例外——碰巧，我就是例外之一——大多数编辑最不想做的一件事就是编辑。这比起和重要的代理人共进午餐或者参加让你引人注目的会议，对职业成功没有那么大的帮助。所以我的猜测是，如果任何编辑确定编辑工作能完成且不会引起问题，他们大概都很乐意把编辑工作丢给别人。对我来说，这就是所有编辑助理前进的道路。
I took his advice and dropped in on my boss, Geoff Kloske, while he was editing a manuscript.
我采纳了他的建议，并在我的老板杰夫·克洛斯克（Geoff Kloske）正在编辑手稿时顺道拜访了他。
Hey.
嘿。
How's it going? It looks like there's a lot there, huh?
怎么样？看起来工作量很大，对吧？
Yeah.
是啊。
If you want, I can take that over later. I mean, if you want to get out of here at some point, I can stay late and-- I don't know-- do a few pages, edit a few pages. If  that's-- I mean--
如果你愿意，我可以稍后接手。我是说，如果你想在某个时候离开这里，我可以留得晚一点，然后——我不知道——做几页，编辑几页。如果那——我是说——
Huh? I'm not going anywhere.
嗯？我哪儿也不去。
Oh. OK, well, if you change your mind--
噢。好吧，如果你改变主意——
Yeah.
是啊。
Well, it was a surprise to me how much secretarial things I was doing-- typing, and fetching and carrying.
嗯，我做多少秘书工作真是令我惊讶——打字、拿东西、搬东西。
From 1984 to 1988, Jenny Blum worked as the assistant to an editor who sits just two offices down from me. I thought her experience would be closer to mine. And it was. Like me, she'd lived in a small Manhattan apartment that she shared with roaches. She'd answered someone else's phone. She knew what a fax machine was. But then her life turned around.
从1984年到1988年，珍妮·布鲁姆（Jenny Blum）曾担任坐在我两间办公室外的一位编辑的助理。我以为她的经历会和我更接近。确实如此。像我一样，她住在曼哈顿的一间小公寓里，与蟑螂为伍。她接听过别人的电话。她知道传真机是什么。但随后她的人生好转了。
Well, I married an author from Simon & Schuster. So I met him in the lobby at Simon & Schuster, where I went to get him to bring him in.
嗯，我嫁给了一位西蒙与舒斯特的作家。所以我在西蒙与舒斯特的大厅里遇见了他，我是去接他进来的。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] traded the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] I got.
[听不清楚] 交易了 [听不清楚] 我得到的。
Tony, you cannot do trades with Anna because she's much younger than you.
托尼（Tony），你不能和安娜（Anna）做交易，因为她比你小得多。
Their kids are now four, five, and seven, Danny, Anna, and Tony, the oldest. When I went to Jenny's house in Connecticut, the three of them and a playmate were running around a large sunny breakfast room about to be picked up for a swimming lesson. It seemed wonderful. I wanted to stay for dinner.
他们的孩子现在四岁、五岁和七岁，丹尼（Danny）、安娜和托尼是老大。当我到珍妮在康涅狄格州的家里时，他们三个和一个玩伴正在阳光充足的大早餐室里跑来跑去，等着去上游泳课。这看起来太美好了。我想留下来吃晚饭。
My early 20s were like rungs on a ladder, editorial assistant, assistant editor, associate editor, editor, senior editor, just like that, dot, dot, dot, dot. I assumed I would be able to have it all. I was gonna have the job, and I was gonna have the kids, and I was gonna make it all work. When I just had Tony, when I just delivered him, I literally made calls to the office from the hospital. I didn't want to be disconnected from working.
我20多岁时就像梯子上的阶梯，编辑助理、助理编辑、副编辑、编辑、高级编辑，就这样，点、点、点、点。我以为我能拥有一切。我会拥有工作，也会拥有孩子，我会让一切顺利运转。当我刚生下托尼，当他刚出生时，我真的从医院给办公室打了电话。我不想与工作断开联系。
I think there is such a thing as maternal instinct. And I think it kicks in. Even more than wanting to be at the office, I really wanted to be with this little baby. I don't know, Nicole. I think I'm really lucky with who I am and what I've done. And I don't think professionally I'm completely happy.
我认为母性本能是确实存在的。而且我觉得它会启动。比起想留在办公室，我确实更想和这个小婴儿在一起。我不知道，妮可。我觉得在我是谁以及我做了什么方面，我真的很幸运。但我并不觉得我在专业上完全快乐。
If I died like John F. Kennedy when I'm 38, am I going to say, "Started a career, bagged it?" I hope not. I hope I'll have something else. I think that's something you're going to have to grapple with.
如果我像约翰·F·肯尼迪一样在38岁时死去，我会说，“开始了一段事业，然后搞砸了”吗？我希望不会。我希望我会拥有别的东西。我觉得这是你需要去挣扎的东西。
So do you think of me somewhat as doomed? It's almost like I'm on a path only by virtue of being a woman. And I can't change that path.
所以你觉得我有点注定失败吗？这几乎就像我是因为身为女性才走上这条道路的。而我无法改变这条道路。
Yes. You are doomed by your biology if you're gonna do, to my mind, the greatest thing you can do as a woman and have a child. You are doomed in a certain way. I think that's true. And I didn't understand it. And I still have a hard time with it. I do feel that it's unfair. I wish I could have my job back.
是的。如果你要——在我看来——做身为女性所能做的最伟大的事情，即生下一个孩子，那么你的生理注定会让你失败。你在某种程度上是注定失败的。我觉得那是真的。我当时没明白。我现在依然很难面对它。我确实觉得这不公平。我希望我能找回我的工作。
Doomed? Not exactly the word I'd wanted to hear. The whole idea of preparing for a family somehow seems so distant and unreal. I'm 22. A family hurt my head to think about. A family thew my map off the map. As I stood over the copying machine the next day, I tried to forget everything Jenny told me.
注定失败？这不是我想听到的词。为家庭做准备的整个想法似乎太遥远而不真实了。我22岁。想到家庭就让我头痛。家庭把我的地图甩出了地图。第二天，当我站在复印机旁时，我试图忘记珍妮告诉我的一切。
I spoke with a few more former assistants. Laurie Chittenden, who became an editor at 25 when she discovered a book that became a New York Times best seller. She told me to stay 'til midnight every night. Brooke Newman, who left Simon & Schuster in the late '60s to fly to Europe with a man she'd met the day before, told me, "Carpe diem." None of this helped me see a map for my own life. In fact, one former assistant, who seemed to have it made, Saul Anton, he's now a freelance magazine writer with a sunny duplex apartment in the West Village. He told me he's looking for the exact same thing I am.
我又和几位前助理聊了聊。劳里·奇滕登（Laurie Chittenden），她在25岁时发现了一本成为《纽约时报》畅销书的著作后成了编辑。她告诉我要每天待到午夜。布鲁克·纽曼（Brooke Newman），她在60年代末离开西蒙与舒斯特，和前一天刚认识的男人飞往欧洲，她告诉我：“活在当下”（Carpe diem）。这些都没有帮我看到自己人生的地图。事实上，一位看起来混得很好的前助理索尔·安东（Saul Anton），他现在是一位自由杂志撰稿人，在西村有一间阳光充足的复式公寓。他告诉我，他也在寻找和我一样的东西。
I really want somebody to give me a map. Usually, this person is my shrink. And twice a week, I go in there, I say, "Look, can I just have the map, please?" And my shrink says, "I don't have a map to give you. You have to write that map." I say, "But I don't want to write the map. If I'm going to have to write the map, I'm going to have to make the map, then I don't need a map."
我真的很想要某个人给我一张地图。通常这个人是我的心理医生。每周两次，我进去说：“听着，我能要一张地图吗，拜托？”我的心理医生说：“我没有地图给你。你必须自己写那张地图。”我说：“但我不想写那张地图。如果我非得写这张地图，如果我非得制造这张地图，那我就不需要地图了。”
At Simon & Schuster, it was all exciting.
在西蒙与舒斯特，一切都很令人兴奋。
I end my story with Phyllis Levy, who had everything I ever wanted out of Simon & Schuster. She started there in 1955. She had the storybook publishing experience, what English majors all across this great nation have always dreamed it could be.
我的故事结尾是菲利斯·利维（Phyllis Levy），她拥有我从西蒙与舒斯特想要得到的一切。她1955年就在那儿开始了。她有故事书般的出版经历，这是全美英语专业学生一直梦想的样子。
There were people who first published D.H. Lawrence. There were people who started sentences with, "As my old friend Clarence Darrow used to say--" It was quite a world to be put in. Everyone was involved.
那里有出版过D.H.劳伦斯（D.H. Lawrence）的人。有把句子开头写成“正如我老朋友克拉伦斯·达罗（Clarence Darrow）常说的那样——”的人。那真是一个值得置身其中的世界。每个人都参与其中。
You could come into Jack's office at the end of the day. Nobody chose to go home because it was much more fun to be there. He had a bar in his office. Everyone came in, sat down, had a drink, and just sat, and talked about books and things. It was nothing to do with publishing today, absolutely nothing. It was total fun.
你可以一天结束时进入杰克的办公室。没人选择回家，因为待在那里更有趣。他在办公室里有个吧台。每个人都进来，坐下，喝一杯，然后就坐着，谈论书籍和事情。那与今天的出版业毫不相关，一点关系都没有。那纯粹是乐趣。
Allow me to provide some context. Editorial assistants these days don't even get to attend editorial meetings, so you can imagine my surprise when Phyllis told me this little story.
容我提供一些背景。编辑助理这些天甚至没资格参加编辑会议，所以你可以想象当我听到菲利斯跟我讲这个小故事时有多惊讶。
One day, Malcolm Cowley, who was a consulting editor and who taught writing at the University of California, appeared in my doorway. He had come to visit. And he handed me a manuscript and said, "What do you think of this?" He gave it to me because I was only person under 60 in the editorial staff. And I took it home that night. And it was Ken Kesey's One Flew Over The Cuckoo's Nest.
有一天，担任咨询编辑并在加州大学教授写作的马尔科姆·考利（Malcolm Cowley）出现在我的门口。他来拜访。他递给我一份手稿说：“你觉得这个怎么样？”他把它交给我，因为我是编辑部里唯一一个不到60岁的人。那天晚上我把它带回家了。那是肯·克西（Ken Kesey）的《飞越疯人院》（One Flew Over The Cuckoo's Nest）。
Well, I came in the next day and went to the editorial meeting. I'd sat through all the previous editorial meetings in total silence, not daring to say a word. And I just said, "I've read the great American novel, and I don't care what any of you say. We have to publish this book." The way a kid would do. It was given to me, and I was the editor of that book then, just as an assistant editor.
嗯，第二天我进公司参加编辑会议。我曾沉默地坐过之前所有的编辑会议，根本不敢说一个字。但我直接说：“我已经读了伟大的美国小说，我不在乎你们怎么说。我们必须出版这本书。”像个孩子那样。这本书交给了我，我当时就是那本书的编辑，仅仅是以助理编辑的身份。
Quick. Reality check. My real job this week--
快。现实核对。我这周真正的工作——
[SOUND OF A PHONE BUZZING]
[电话嗡嗡声]
Yeah.
喂。
Do we have any light bulbs?
我们有灯泡吗？
Light bulbs?
灯泡？
It's kind of dark in here.
这里有点暗。
I don't-- I can check the supply closet, I guess.
我不——我想我可以查查储物柜。
Can you go get some light bulbs?
你能去拿些灯泡吗？
OK.
好的。
So there was Phyllis, schmoozing with literary icons, editing the great American novel. But the most amazing thing about her? She didn't even want the fate she ended up with.
所以菲利斯就是那样，与文学偶像周旋，编辑着伟大的美国小说。但关于她最令人惊讶的事情是什么？她甚至并没有追求她最终得到的命运。
We're talking 1950s. I was programmed really-- we all were then-- to think of work as not very important and something you did to have a good time for a while until Mr. Perfect came along.
那是50年代。我真的被编程了——我们当时都被编程了——认为工作不是很重要，是你为了享受时光而做的事情，直到完美先生出现。
So what happened with the Mr. Perfect?
那完美先生后来怎么样了？
Never mind. I'm not going to get into that. There were actually two Mr. Perfects, and both of them broke my heart. And that's that story.
别管那个。我不想谈论那个。其实有两个完美先生，他们都伤了我的心。这就是那个故事。
Phyllis became a magazine editor. She worked in Hollywood for a while, jetting across the country, reading manuscripts. Now she's the books editor for Good Housekeeping. I looked at her, composed, elegant, sparkling, and thought about how much she'd been through, how much more she'd been through than me.
菲利斯成了杂志编辑。她在好莱坞工作过一段时间，往返于全国各地，阅读手稿。现在她是《好管家》（Good Housekeeping）的图书编辑。我看着她，优雅、镇定、闪耀，想到她经历了多少，她经历了多少比我多得多的事。
My whole life up until this point has been school. And in school, you always know that you're in the right place because when you're 15 years old, there's nowhere else you're supposed to be except high school. And you always feel like you're on this motorcycle, and you see the horizon in front of you, and it's the future. I always felt like hitting that horizon, like hitting that future was going to be like flying, like soaring. And I guess--
到目前为止，我的整个人生都是学校。在学校里，你总是知道你在正确的地方，因为当你15岁时，除了高中，你没什么地方该去。你总是觉得自己在骑摩托车，你看到前面的地平线，那就是未来。我一直觉得触碰那个地平线，触碰那个未来会像飞行一样，像翱翔一样。我想——
Life is not like that. That's a very young person's idea of life. It's just not like that. There's not an epiphany. There's not something you know at the beginning that's your pa-- not at all.
生活不是那样的。那是很年轻的人对生活的想法。根本就不是那样。没有顿悟。你在开头不知道你的路径——根本没有。
You take each step where it leads you. And if you follow your heart with as much practicality as you have to have-- you have to have that. But I've always been someone who followed my heart. And probably if I've said, well, if you had it ever to do over again, would you change this, would you change that? And the thing is, to quote Hemingway, "Isn't it pretty to think so?"
你每走一步，就看它带你去向哪里。如果你以你必须具备的务实态度追随你的心——你必须具备那种态度。但我一直是个追随内心的人。如果我问，嗯，如果你能重来一次，你会改变这个吗，你会改变那个吗？问题是，借用海明威的话，“哪怕那是真的，不是很美好吗？”
I've even said to myself about the two great loves of my life, who, if I'd only chosen other people, I could've had families and children, blah, blah, blah. If I were given those same choices again, even knowing, even knowing that they ended badly, I would make those same choices again. Because I believe in following your heart, and that's what I do. And it's worked out just fine. I've had an awfully good time.
关于我生命中的两位挚爱，我甚至对自己说过，如果我当初选择了别人，我本可以拥有家庭和孩子，巴拉巴拉。如果给我同样的重新选择机会，哪怕知道，哪怕知道结果很糟糕，我依然会做出同样的决定。因为我相信追随内心，这就是我所做的。结果还不错。我度过了非常美妙的时光。
I thought over Phyllis's words later on, at the copier. The problem with following your heart is that the heart is not a compass. It spins around and around, sometimes pausing, wobbly, landing nowhere in particular for very long. My heart swept half-circles to California, swung back to going to grad school, and plunked down in front of the TV, not wanting to bother with either.
后来在复印机旁，我细细咀嚼了菲利斯的话。追随内心的问题在于，心不是指南针。它转来转去，有时停顿、晃荡，很久都没降落在任何特定的地方。我的心曾半圆弧地扫向加州，又转回读研究生，最后一头栽进电视前，两者都不想费心。
My heart once landed on a guy named John, whose heart landed on a woman in Belize. And then my heart didn't do much of anything for a while. But then it started back up again. It always does.
我的心曾经降落在一个叫约翰的男人身上，而他的心降落在了伯利兹的一个女人身上。然后我的心有一阵子没做什么。但后来它又重新启动了。总是会这样。
Nicole Graev, professional assistant.
妮可·格雷夫，职业助理。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Susan Burton, Julie Snyder, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Paul Tough, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Starlee Kine, and Sylvia Lemus. Musical help from Marika Partridge.
嗯，今天的节目由亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我制作，苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）参与制作。特约编辑：杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）、艾利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）以及顾问萨拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。制作协助：托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）、斯塔利·基恩（Starlee Kine）和西尔维娅·莱姆斯（Sylvia Lemus）。音乐协助：玛丽卡·帕特里奇（Marika Partridge）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for absolutely free. Free, free, free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. That's thislife, one word, no space. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买本节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。或者你知道你可以完全免费地收听我们的大部分节目。免费、免费、免费，就在互联网上我们的网站 www.thislife.org。那是“thislife”，一个单词，中间没空格。感谢运营网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who wanders every day through WBEZ's hallways, saying,
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他每天徘徊在WBEZ的走廊里，说道：
There is not a sentient being for hundreds of miles probably. I am the only one wandering around here.
方圆几百英里内连一个有知觉的生命都没有。我是这里唯一走动的人。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
Dear God, give me what I want, or I'm going to go shop elsewhere.
天哪，给我想要的，不然我就去别处购物了。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。